Aladin is directed by Guy Ritchie and is
the latest Disney live-action remake
this time retelling the original 1992
animated classic of the same name and it
tells a story of a streetwise thief
named Aladdin who comes across Princess
Jasmine meets a genie and fights the
evil Jafar
seriously though before I get into the
review this movie has been met with so
much online criticism because Will Smith
is blue and people just thought that was
so goddamn hilarious and I guess it
doesn't really look that good having
seen the actual movie I have some things
to say about it but it's not like Sonic
the Hedgehog where like as soon as I saw
the trailer I wanted to actually burn
all of my Sonic games in retaliation for
the horrific thing that I was witnessing
it wasn't like that I still like the
original Aladdin it's funny though
having actually seen the movie Will
Smith is the least of my concerns if
anything he actually kept the movie more
charismatic than it was whenever he
wasn't on screen I can't really focus on
the music and say the music is this
great highlight because it's just the
songs from the original yes there's some
new material and yes it's all good but
I'm just having a hard time getting
excited about these Disney live-action
remakes because it's essentially taking
something we all love already and saying
hey let's look at it through this light
sometimes that works I really did like
Jon Favreau's the jungle book and the
Cinderella film wasn't too bad either
because those films I can see how they
could be real life a boy in the jungle
there are animals yes they talk and
stuff but at its core I can picture that
in real life we've had so many
adaptations of that story anyway
same with Cinderella it's something I
can picture in real life Aladdin that's
a little hard we have this over-the-top
genie the princess with her friendly
Siberian tiger you know like it's kind
of hard to picture some of these things
in real life and so that's a struggle
this film has because the movie is
trying too hard to evoke the feel of the
animation for one thing the animated
film is 90 minutes it's tight it's
contained it's compact it works
this film is 2 hours and 8 minutes
there's a lot of new stuff and you can
feel it you can feel the story start to
get stretched and you can feel these
characters getting stretched to the
point where they don't have anywhere
else to go one of my biggest concerns
with the film though lies in the
performances namely the Aladdin
character at times he feels like he's
trying too hard to be like the animated
version that nervous cute anxious
quality that Aladdin had in the first
film where he was trying to be something
he wasn't that works in animated form
but when you translate that exaggerated
element of performing to live-action it
comes off very cheesy and I felt that
most of the acting in this film was very
bland
Will Smith is fine as the genie once you
get over the fact that you're looking at
Will Smith has this giant Genie
he's actually the most entertaining part
of the film in fact when he wasn't on
screen I found myself relentlessly bored
as far as the other characters go I
would say Naomi Scott as Jasmine gave
the best performance she felt like she
was really trying with this role and I'm
sure the actor who portrayed Aladdin was
also trying I have nothing against these
actors you guys know me I actually I
really am uncomfortable speaking
negatively about actors because I know
how hard their job is and it always
makes me feel icky every time I do it
but I really do think that most of the
performances in this movie were very
weak the worst though is Jafar and I've
seen this actor in another film called
what happened to Monday with Noomi
Rapace on Netflix and he was really good
in that movie so this leads me to
believe that there was something about
the way this film was directed by Guy
Ritchie that just kept everything very
stilted and wooden it at times does feel
like a low-rent stage play version of
Aladdin even down to the way it looks
the costumes look so clean and perfect
they don't look dusty or dirty there's
no sand or dirt on them there's there's
a few scenes where they're literally
rolling around in the sand that's
different but when they're walking
around the city they just look like they
were freshly laundered it kind of
reminded me of Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull one of my
biggest issues with that movie was just
how clean and glossy everything looked
whereas the original three they just
felt like they were shot in a backyard
somewhere
looked so so gritty this movie
everything looks clean so relentlessly
perfect looking that it really did feel
like I was watching something shot
constantly on a soundstage I never ever
had that disconnect with reality I
always felt like I was watching
something that was filmed never got into
the movie there were some sequences that
were entertaining most of them being
really over-the-top Genie songs it also
feels like Guy Ritchie may have been
uncertain about how to approach a
musical because some of the sequences
where characters are singing are just
very bland the camera just follows them
around as they walk and there isn't much
movement there isn't much Flair to it
every time Jafar was on screen I
honestly felt like laughing his look he
looked like he was in a Power Rangers
episode I mean he's got this big Cobra
staff and there are just certain things
that work in an animation and they just
don't work in a live-action whenever you
do a remake of something that was in a
different form before you have to look
at that and say what works as a drawing
and what doesn't because just recreating
what we liked in animation form clearly
just doesn't always work but in regards
to Will Smith he had a major uphill
battle with this character I'm sure he
was probably horrified at the potential
of you know inhabiting this character
there are a few Disney characters as
renowned as the genie and there are even
less as synonymous with their actors as
Robin Williams is with the genie those
two things are almost inseparable
I mean Simba is probably a more famous
character than the genie but when you
think of Simba do you think of Matthew
Broderick probably not but when you
think of the genie you think of Robin
Williams it's impossible not to
does he trample all over that character
no no he's fine it's just that you kind
of have to get over the fact that it's
this giant CGI Will Smith dancing around
it just it doesn't always work when he
plays himself though I thought it was
really charming and he did a good job in
the movie he's easily honestly the best
part of the movie which is funny because
he was the most widely scrutinized
aspect of it before there are times
where you can feel like the actors are
trying to break free from whatever
control they're under and they're trying
to just be a little more lively but for
the most part some of the dialogue and
some of the performances are
cringe-worthy the CGI is very noticeable
and the sets looked like sets is it as
bad as the internet thought it was going
to be I guess not I mean the thing that
everyone was worried about was probably
my favorite part of the movie it's
everything else around it the stuff that
people just assumed would be good that I
thought was bad I'm gonna give a Ladin a
c-minus guys I just want to say thank
you for continuing to watch my videos
it's awesome I appreciate it
every once in a while I just want to
remind you guys that I really appreciate
that you guys are here so thank you so
much for doing that look forward to more
reviews very soon and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]